hello everyone
my name is stephen calciano and i'm the
psyx biopharmaceutical market
development manager for capillary
electrophoresis in the americas
i'm happy to introduce our speaker peter
halper
who obtained his degree in biochemistry
and cell biology from the university of
california
san diego peter has over 12 years of
experience
in biopharma including as an analytical
chemist
at the eli lillian company where he was
responsible for developing the
analytical control strategy for
bioproducts
peter currently works at psyx in redwood
city california
where he is responsible for developing
and optimizing
ce applications and providing customer
demo sample analysis support
thank you so much for joining us today
peter and i look forward to your
presentation
thank you very much for the introduction
as mentioned
i have a long history as an analytical
development chemist
who like probably most of you are now
was always searching for ways to improve
my workflow really improve
the methods that i had and at the end of
the day
i was always looking for a better
understanding
of the analytes that i'm working with
well i can always be one
step ahead of the questions that our
regulatory agencies
would ultimately ask us i'm excited to
be here
you know to be able to share a
potentially new way
to characterize residual nucleic acids
we'll start today with a brief
background introduction
to those residual nucleic acids where
they're coming from
why we characterize them then we'll look
at ways we're currently performing this
type of characterization
from there we'll dive into how we can
really improve upon those workflows to
give ourselves
and the agencies that are in charge of
approving our blas
a better understanding of what is in our
products
let's start with looking into where
these residual nucleic acids come from
right our cell culture processes
now the bioproducts we manufacture and
we hope to bring the market are produced
using
cell culture platforms and in recent
years
new platforms have become really
increasingly attractive to our
manufacturing teams
they're based on production systems
that can provide really a number of
different advantages
such as a broad selection of candidate
cell lines for product development
the possibility of more stringent
product control
and better product safety
or even ease of scaling up your
production
and potentially or reduce manufacturing
costs
but there are always going to be safety
concerns that are specific
to these cell culture derived vaccines
in biologics
these need to be addressed before
regulatory approval of the products can
be made
many of these issues stem from process
dirt
process residuals these are all derived
from the cell substrates
that remain in our final products as
impurities
now the guidelines that define
acceptable
levels of processed residuals in
biologics
really by various regulatory agencies
have evolved
over the last few decades we can look
all the way back to 1987
when the world health organization was
aware of the risk associated with
residual dna
they set a limit of equal of less than
or equal to 100 picograms
in a single parental dose
well that limit was really intended to
minimize
the potential oncogenic risk of residual
dna
from products derived from these
continuous cell lines that we use
but subsequent information suggested
that
the residual dna from these cell lines
had a much lower risk than
they really assumed and they should just
be considered a general impurity
following that thought in 1998 the limit
was increased
to less than or equal to 10 nanogram per
dose
then in 2001 the fda recommended that
size should also be taken into account
when evaluating residual dna
in 2010 they followed up that with the
recommendation
that dna fragments should be reduced to
below the size of a functional gene
roughly about 200 base pairs
now today regulatory bodies really agree
on taking a risk assessment approach
where we're taking into account
the intended use of the product along
with the size
the quantity and even the activity of
those residual fragments
really this is a case-by-case risk-based
approach
that they've advocated in recognition
that residual dna in some products might
be higher than 10 nanogram per dose
and it might be very difficult to reach
that 10 nanogram per dose
level without impairing the potency of
the product
and then our gene therapy space where we
have a lot of
cell-based therapies and gene-based
therapies when we have lower titers that
becomes even harder to reach
a harder threshold to reach
so how are we meeting these
characterizations mean today
these these needs today and how can we
do
better
well one approach we use is just
quantitation by pico-green
we have a dye that binds
double-stranded dna and generates a
fluorescent signal
whereas unbound eye emits very little
fluorescent signal
pretty simple one of the advantages
right
it's very simple to use very low cost
and it has some utility for samples with
high levels of dna
that you might see in your upstream
processes
but pico green is relatively poor
sensitivity and can
really only detect about 0.2 nanograms
of a pure solution of dna
like all methods for residuals it's also
prone to interference from other
components
and it doesn't always give reliable
results unless you've very well
extracted it
but the lack of sensitivity might be its
most major limitation
especially given the guidance from the
who
to where you really want to set your
threshold at about 10 nanogram per dose
therefore we generally don't want to use
this for final product release
especially when we're using high dose
products
another technique that's used for
residual dna quantitation is
hybridization here we're using probes
designed to recognize specific
target single stranded sequences that
are labeled with either
a radioactive tag or a fluorescent dye
and we hybridize it with denatured dna
samples immobilized
on the membrane the amount of dna is
estimated from the signal
intensity relative to a standard which
is generally the same genomic dna from
the host
the advantages here is that it's similar
to a southern blot
which is widely used among our peers
so there's really no special training
needed and the cost is relatively low
and this can also estimate the size of
dna
because you can electrophorese the dna
prior to blotting across your standards
of different size range so like
pico green though one of the major
drawbacks is another lack of sensitivity
usually
right about 10 nanogram per mil
it also has a pretty long testing time
up to upwards of two days
and that's really why we've steered away
from this method in
more recent years
thresholds is another assay that that's
been used
here we have a single-stranded dna
binding protein
that's used to bind and capture
denatured single-stranded residual dna
and a urease conjugated
anti-dna antibody is used to detect the
bound dna
and then by hydrolyzing that urea by an
enzyme will produce a change in ph
and the rate of change in that ph is
proportional to the amount of dna in the
sample
which can then be calculated relative to
a signal on a standard
this method is very sensitive and down
to the one to three picogram range
and it has a very standardized protocol
but
the throughput is low that doesn't help
us and the cost is high
another point that we have to consider
here is just the limitation of the
detectable
size of dna fragments
because it depends on binding of a
denatured dna to a single strand of dna
binding protein and the anti-dna
antibody dna fragments
lower than about 600 base pairs are
going to be missed
and during bioprocessing it's certainly
possible that a dna
strand will be sheared to smaller sizes
during treatment right whether through
filters or
purification columns we really need to
know that size that size is becoming
increasingly important
to better characterize our product
now pcr-based technology can also be
used for the determination of residual
dna
and is now easily the most widely used
method in our industry
during the pcr reaction the sequence
specific dna
template is amplified to produce
billions of copies within a couple hours
and that allows for the detection of
extremely low levels of dna
now pcr products are going to be
measured in the early stage of
application
amplification when we're using real-time
pcr
which allows for an accurate
quantitation of the residual dna in our
products because
there's a high correlation between the
level of dna of starting dna
and the signals detected in that early
exponential phase
now you can use several different
chemistries right three very common ones
include cyber green or dye based primer
signaling
tacman but as with
most assays that we've come to love and
you know enjoy
we know that speed doesn't equal
precision which is one of the major
disadvantages here
and this assay in particular doesn't
have the ability to
provide size determination
or the ability really to detect
fragments that don't contain the target
sequence
so here again you're missing a fair
amount of crucial information
so on the whole these these four
technologies have a variety of strengths
some are really fast
some are very low cost some have very
simple methodologies
but none of them really combines all of
them
and most don't provide
size characterization which is really
important
in the eyes of our regulatory bodies
and in fact i think we can sum up the
shortcomings
in three ways they have an adequate
sensitivity
they have insufficient selectivity
and they have too much rigidity
where can we go from here
we really have to broaden our search to
new technology
that can rise to the challenge think
beyond where we're
used to playing
and that search can bring us to tools
commonly used in analytical development
that we already have in our labs
so we turn to capillary electrophoresis
to better
characterize our process residuals
now ce can provide a convenient method
for nucleic acid characterization
this type of characterization has been
done on our platform for
really decades and it has dedicated
kit-based solutions already made
the psyx double-stranded stranded dna
1000 kit
is one of those kits that's suitable
really for
rapid and automated analysis of these
products
it has a replaceable gel buffer and a
coated capillary that gives us
really good reproducibility which will
then allow us to quickly characterize
our products during process development
during manufacturing during release
all very important phases of the product
life cycle
now let's look at this kitten accent
right so on the top
left of our screen you can see that this
kit
can provide baseline resolution of 11
restriction enzyme fragments of a
bacteriophage dna
their estimated lengths are listed there
the separation was performed with just a
30 centimeter effective length dna
coated capillary
that same double stranded dna 1000 gel
and lift floor enhanced ce die
the two red arrows that you see really
just indicate
receiving potential we see two fragments
with the 10 base pair size difference
baseline resolved
on the bottom left we see an example of
a successful separation and sizing of
restriction fragments of virus and
plasmid dna using the same kit
peaks in green font are from a h3
restriction
fragments
of a bacteriophage dna and then a linear
plasmid dna is labeled in blue font
and then fragments from a 1kb plus dna
ladder are labeled in black font
it provides very strong separation
but another aspect very important aspect
of residual characterization is
sensitivity because without sufficient
sensitivity
we can't prove that we're at or below
the threshold of 10 nanogram per dose
so here we see serial dilution of the
same 11 restriction fragments of
bacteriophage dna
and using the same lift floor enhanced c
stain
we could obtain a lod below one nanogram
per ml
and an loq of just under two nanogram
per ml
pretty sensitive
but i know just like you know that we
always have people out there
pushing the limits of instrumentation
just like i did for many years
and this application that we're showing
today is really no different
well the scientists at metamune now a
member of astrazeneca
were one set of those users that did
that
they really pushed the limits of this
type of assay
they explored ways to increase
sensitivity
by focusing on using different dies
optimizing their sample matrices
optimizing their injection parameters
and even looking at the dye
concentration to reach
what was previously unheard of levels of
sensitivity
because they were able to achieve an loq
of
0.025 nanogram per ml using the standard
and they were even able to identify the
same 10
ladder peaks at 0.00625
nanogram per ml so that is amazingly
sensitive that is
great work by that team and by following
some of those parameters
not all of them i was able to easily
achieve
sensitive and reproducible separations
well below that one
nanogram per ml range and i understood
that had i followed
all everything they were doing i would
have likely achieved even far
greater sensitivity that they were able
to
but how can we put that great work to
work for us
right luckily we don't have to rely on
analyzing a full ladder
and comparing it to each sample we want
to analyze
when we want to characterize our
residuals
we can really zero in on specific dna
fragments that are most important
and here as we've been talking about
following our regulatory guidance
that 200 base pair fragment is really
the threshold where we want to be able
to accurately measure
we need to have the sensitivity sort of
to see this line in the sand
in this case the peak in the
electrophorogram
and how that compares to our samples
so we can analyze the 200 base pair dna
fragment by itself
and we can compare it to residual dna
samples that we analyze
that's certainly better than running a
whole ladder standard
and it's fine that's a fine solution we
have robust migration times
we can get very sensitive method
but we should always push ourselves to
do better
because if we don't well someone else is
going to do it first
but what else can we do
why not just spike the marker into the
sample itself
it can give us a clear marker of that
200 base pair threshold we want to be
under
ideally and it allows for really the
simplest of integration because you have
a well-defined peak right there at 200
base pair
and we have complete confidence in the
results we obtained
so here we are we're looking at a
residual dna sample with the 200 base
pair marker spiked in
at a concentration of about one nanogram
per ml
you can easily estimate the total dna
within the electropyrogram if you'd like
we have linear response that we've shown
earlier
or you can simply rely on
really the electrophoreogram's ability
to characterize your size of dna if you
quantitate it by another method
but in any case you get a better picture
you get
a more complete picture you get better
characterization
you get more confidence in the product
you're hoping to bring to market
and in the continually evolving gene
therapy
cell spirit therapy space really in all
of biopharma
this is what you're going to need right
now this is what you're going to be
pushed to
in the very near future
now we move to residual rna
can we take what we've learned analyzing
that residual dna and put it to use when
we need to characterize
characterize residual rna
of course but why aren't i
why why are we bothering well
certain expression systems can leave
trace amounts of residual rna
one of the more commonly ones that's
used is e coli
and that you can certainly be harnessed
to express insulins
proteins plasmins
plasmids really are incredibly important
by themselves
how important well
really incredibly important to our
therapeutics
they can be used by themselves as
vaccines they can be used as a gene
delivery vehicle
they can be used to make process
intermediates for viral vectors such as
aavs and lentiviruses
truly important
and with all this regulatory focus on
residual dna why are we worrying about
rna
well to be honest right we need to be
worried about any impurity we have in
our sample
in our processes and it needs to be
minimized and controlled and we need to
prove to our regulatory body is that we
have control over it
that we can see it if it's there
the rna in particular can turn genes on
and off
it can alter other molecules and
reactions they can even build
proteins right so we we should want
we should all want to minimize the
introduction of any host cell products
into our patients that we're looking to
help rna
certainly no exception to the rule
now we can easily analyze plasmids using
ce technology
using that same double stranded dna 1000
kit actually
this has been done for many many years
to monitor the different isoforms
but to characterize rna we need to take
a slightly
different approach
and in fact we have a whole different
kit just for that
our single-stranded dna 100r kit really
harnesses the same capillary gel
electrophoresis technology
as our double-stranded dna 1000 kit
but here we use a denaturant to limit
the secondary
structure of rna to ensure a more
accurate size
estimation and while this kit
out of the box is really designed
for rapid and reproducible separation
between 100 or 10 and 100 bases
by simply diluting the deceiving gel you
can get a much
greater range leaving range
for your analyte that needs to be
characterized so it's really
customizable to the size you're looking
to monitor
and we have another solution that isn't
currently a kit
but it's it's really optimized to
separate up to about five or six
thousand bases
and in both cases we have great
sensitivity
here we show an loq of about 0.3
nanogram per ml an
lod of about 0.1 or really below 0.1
actually
nanogram per ml even here
we can take the learnings from our
residual dna analysis and put them to
work to further increase its sensitivity
we optimize our
dye concentration we optimize our
injection parameters
we find
by looking at some real world samples
that rna that's carried over from our
various processes can have quite
the size distribution
there really isn't necessarily going to
be one main fragment for us to
characterize it can be
spread out all over the place
we take what we learned and apply it
we increase our sensitivity we
characterize a sample against a size
standard
or if we have it if it's available a
single rna fragment
here in this sample as well we can see
quite a size distribution of rna
here we're looking at multiple products
see the size distribution real samples
each one needs to be monitored each one
should be characterized to better
understand how to minimize its presence
the final question that i wanted to
explore and try to solve
was whether we could monitor residual
dna in the presence of a plasmid
we took that same plasma that you saw a
few slides ago
we also took some e coli rna which you
can see in the bottom left
and then the top left you see the
plasmid now that's under denaturing
conditions with a lot of changes to the
method than
you would in just analyzing that plasmid
by itself for its isoforms
then you spike in e coli at just a 0.1
percent level relative to the plasmid
concentration
we can see we can detect its presence
which is great but we also see that the
plasmid is
likely coal migrating with at least some
of the rna that we wish to characterize
so i like to call this a work in
progress
so we have today what we've been
discussing really is an approach
to characterize residual host cell dna
by capillary gel electrophoresis with
laser induced fluorescence detection
that allows for a great estimation of
the size
and the ability to quantify the amount
and with a few small changes to our gel
we can characterize rna as well
additional sample preparation steps are
probably required to eliminate
interference from a plasmid
depending on its size i think we have a
really good starting point to continue
developing that
approach
and with that i would like to thank
everyone
for taking their time today to listen to
me
and would like to turn this back over to
stephen for the question and answer
session
thank you peter for these great insights
into a high performance residual nucleic
acid characterization workflow
we're now going to move over to the q a
portion of the webinar
but before we do we'd like to pose a
question to the audience
so what are uh your biggest challenges
related to nuclear residual nucleic acid
analysis workflows
you'll see a few answers that you can
select from on the screen
fantastic well thank you everyone for
your feedback
um and we'll look to move over to the
question and answer portion of the
session
so please remember to post your
questions to peter by using the ask a
question box
on the left hand side of your screen so
it looks like we've
got a few coming in um
and we will start with
uh this first question so are these low
sensitivities exclusive to lift
detection
and what can be achieved with pda
detection
yes so everything that we showed here
was
using laser-induced fluorescence
detection using a few different dyes
depending on the application whether it
was rna or dna
you can't use pda the pda detector with
this
capillary because it is a coated
capillary and the pda will actually
burn off the coating but you can use the
uv detector
it's going to be more or less the same
it just has a single wave like band pass
filter before the light
hits the capillary window and i guess in
general i would say
the lift affords you at least 10 times
greater sensitivity
but i think that can be a little tricky
here because these dies are so
powerful really compared to some of the
other ones on the market that it's
probably
even beyond that even beyond 10 times
but i don't have
an exact number
off the top of my head here because we
can use a lot of the same
tricks that we did to increase the
sensitivity that you know how we're
injecting the sample
et cetera some of those modifications
but the
enhanced sensitivity of the lift gets us
really pushes it down to
that sub nanogram per mil level
fantastic thanks so much peter i guess
while we're on the topic
can you um expand on what dives
you were using for the results shown
sure so
let's see for for this
where we we started was using our
enhanced ce lift floor dye so that is
one that we
sell through sciax that you can order
and that is pretty sensitive dye but to
really push it
farther we saw here this is using cyber
green one
which has a um
it's going to bind more specifically to
just dna
whereas the enhanced four die will have
you know some of them
less of a could bind more towards either
one towards dna or rna
and then when we're moving on to
here to the rna analysis that's where
we're switching to cyber green two
so cyber green two now is going to be
much uh have a higher binding efficiency
to
rna or single stranded dna
but both of those are do have a much
higher quantum yield than
that enhanced left floor die so that's
why we do that to push
you know really even farther the limits
of what what we can go
great thank you so much um we do have a
question
related to um you know how did you
optimize the sample injection
well that's yeah um the sample injection
there's a few ways and at first i
i started with our normal injection
parameters i guess which would be about
1 000 volts for a couple seconds two to
four seconds
and looking at the publication that i
referenced from metamune
they went all the way up to 8000 volts
for about 20 seconds
so that's going to be the high end so i
check a few in between maybe 5 000 volts
for 10 20 seconds and just see how it
all plays out and
can you really go even push it above
that 8 000 20 second
range so there is definitely a
diminishing returns i would say
if you go too high or too long
your reproducibility kind of suffers so
i saw a good reproducibility where
at that eight thousand volt for 20
second range
well i know some other of our customers
are
backed down a little bit but what you
saw for most all of these
results shown was using that 8 000 volts
for 20 seconds
perfect thank you so much we've got a
workflow related question so this one is
assume detecting cho dna
is the dsdna ready-made kit
able to target this host dna
or is there something the user has to do
related to primers or any other reagents
so yeah there are no primers that are
involved
at best you'd you know potentially need
to
extract it or or concentrate it
depending on what
that residual dna is but if it's there i
mean you see
um the the the
electrophoreogram shown from a host of
different sources
um different production types but yeah
there's nothing
i almost say there's nothing special
about cho dna
that is going to cause an issue here
so it really is just the the dye itself
intercalating between those nucleic
acids and the dna strand
fantastic thank you um one additional
question about
um does the kid quantify free floating
dna
in the sample only or can it detect
fragments that are partially attached to
a product for example partially
encapsulated dna
by aav capsids
that's an interesting question i guess i
didn't look at that certainly it can
quantify free floating dna because if
the dye can
get in there and bind to it then that's
what's going to fluoresce
i don't know if it could
enter well they say partially
encapsulated
so i'm not i'm not sure if that the
b2a is going to be still attached then
to some part of the capsid or
or what so that might be something that
i have to to go back and
and dig a little deeper into sure not a
problem
thank you very much um we have a
question related to
analysis time so what is the shortest
analysis time
including preconditioning and rinsing
for a single sample
um conditioning for at the start of a
run
is probably in the 10 to 15 minute range
and then a sample analysis
that can vary a little bit depending on
the length of dna you're using
or the concentration of gel polymer that
you've chosen that is
optimal for your sample because
certainly you can use it right out of
the box
at just the the normal reconstitution
volume
and that will give you some level of
polymer that gives you a certain saving
range if you dilute that out further you
get a larger seaming range
or you'll be able to separate in a
shorter amount of time
because your dna will be flowing through
that polymer faster
but i would guess about 20 minutes is a
fair
estimate for a separation time it might
go up to 30 depending if you're
looking at something really big and
wanna
uh relatively big i guess or need to
keep that
resolution between the peaks i think
20 minutes or so is probably a fair
estimate for separation time
great thank you very much uh somewhat
related question
um what are ways to extend the life
of the capillary
yeah so because we're using a coated
capillary
um you know you can see see degradation
over time and that is something that a
number of our customers have
looked into optimizing and i
didn't have first-hand experience
putting this to
to work but i can share what they've
shared with me
one customer has used
methanol rinses both in the conditioning
and shut down steps
to i assume to keep the
dye or just to help rinse the dye out
another one found that a shutdown method
with gel that doesn't contain the dye
actually extended the life
quite considerably so there is you know
potentially some thought there that
the dye resting in the capillary for
extended periods of time is not
ideal but those are very simple tweaks
that you can make to the shutdown method
or to your buffer trace setup
to just get some more lifetime out of
that capillary and still get great
results from every day
every every analysis perfect
some great tips to share we do have
another
workflow related question so after
extracting dna
is there any special sample treatment or
preparation before going
uh for analysis on the ce
not particularly what i would say is you
want to be cognizant of the ionic
strength that's left over in your sample
so in the metamum paper they discussed
going to a certain amount of te
so of the tris edta buffer that they
were extracting in
and they found an optimal range which
was
but i can't remember off the top of my
head um but
i didn't do that that was something that
i could have explored but because i
didn't have
didn't do all those um well really i
didn't have all that much material to
work with
i'll be honest so doing a buffer
exchange on a minimal amount of material
isn't exactly easy
but that that would be the only thing
that i would say to watch out for is
just
try to keep the level of ionic strength
lower because we are using
electrokinetic injection and we are
really pushing the limits of that
um so the less salt in there the less
salt is injected
okay understood great thanks so much um
one other question if there is a large
amount of residual dna
and the range of fragments is large with
many fragments
up to 50 000 base pairs uh
would the ce system detect a smear and
what is
the i think it's the limit of size
oh that's an interesting one so
if there's a large amount of residual
dna
you'd certainly want to dilute it out to
the point that you're not
maxing out the detector so that's the
first thing you also want to make sure
that you have enough
dye or an optimal concentration of dye
in the gel so that was one of the things
that we looked at is what is the optimal
concentration for low levels
and you can kind of see a curve where
you hit an optimal point for low levels
of trace
dna but if you have higher amounts that
ratio of dye to gel might not be optimal
anymore
so that's another thing you have to
watch out for but for size up to 50
000 i definitely haven't looked at that
we have done
plasmids up about 20
000 and that's really just looking at
dilutions of gel so i don't know that
you necessarily see a smear
but you probably wouldn't get as sharp
of peaks as you do in the
the smaller range or it may just be that
your resolution between peaks isn't as
great
but that that would be an interesting
thing to look at is what
is the optimal
polymer concentration for for such a
sample
i haven't seen a standard that goes up
to that range so it'd be
a little hard for me to to test but that
that's where i would start is just look
at different dilutions of gel
and different concentrations of dye in
that gel
fantastic thank you so much um i
think we may have had a few more just
comments just give me one second
um
all right so i think that these are i've
already been addressed so
um with that said i think we're you know
ready to wrap up the
q a portion of the webinar here today
um so peter thank you so much uh for
your presentation and thank you
a big thank you to the audience uh for
attending today's webinar
and staying interactive during the q a
session so um
thank you very much everyone we look
forward to connecting again in the
future